all right welcome everybody we are here
for day six of Donald Trump Senate
impeachment trial notable today is that
Donald Trump's defense team will
actually start we are going to hear from
presumably Jay Sekulow and Pat's abalone
and they are going to make the case that
well the case that Trump did nothing
wrong and I assume we will hear lots of
a lot lots about Joe Biden and we will
hear about BER yzma and we will hear
about all sorts of things that have
nothing to do actually with whether
Donald Trump is guilty of the two things
he is accused of of course abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress
starting at the top of the hour it is a
shorter session today they said
yesterday it would probably be a ten to
one sort of thing eastern time getting
under way and about somewhere between 18
and 25 minutes I would guess we will be
here throughout I will take questions
via super chat I will take questions via
twitch as well if you are playing along
today might I suggest you check out the
bingo board that I tweeted last night
this these are what I expect to be the
key phrases I would be looking for
tonight and of course you know I think
there will be a lot of winners how how
much will Obama be mentioned tonight
will determine called be used of course
that's how Donald Trump refers to his
phone call on July 25th with the
Ukrainian president Wilburys Zuma be
mentioned lawyer lawsuits instantly
lawyer lawsuits maybe should have
actually been the it should have been
the central square but which it's not
lawyer lawsuits a phrase that Jay
Sekulow has developed over the last few
days
quid pro quo will be mentioned I think
Hillary's emails may actually be
mentioned witch-hunt almost guaranteed
Biden really should be the central
square I think that will be the subject
here and then of course corruption
corruption in the context being that
corruption is what this was really all
about this was why Donald Trump did all
of the things that he did Donald Trump
already very very active tweeting this
morning tweeting just five
minutes ago our case against lyin
cheatin little Adam shifty shift cryin
Chuck Schumer nervous Nancy Pelosi their
leader dumb as a rock
AOC and the entire radical left do
nothing Democrat party starts today at
10:00 a.m. on Fox News Oh a NN or fake
news CNN or fake news MSDN see now
interestingly about that Fox News has
been running a lot of the impeachment
hearings on mute with my pillow
commercials over it so you're not going
to get a great sense of what they say
there unless today they'll do it
differently Oh a NN is an e Oh a a and
then if anybody has ever seen it it
looks like a porn parody of Fox News
let's see if I can actually show you a
clip check this out
actually that's not let's see if they
have an actual just regular clip Ukraine
hoax oh my goodness there's a particular
clip or where you see it it's like is
this a porn parody managers are wrapping
up their opening arguments today again
the president's legal team is set to be
laying out their case tomorrow yeah I
mean can barely put together a coherent
sentence off of that teleprompter so
that is the big news today we are going
to be hearing from Donald Trump's legal
team play along with a trump lawyer
bingo that's at my Twitter account at D
Pakman and you can you can reshare that
and retweet it and I will take questions
and I would love to hear from people but
first I do need to thank some people
because yes actually you know what let
me do the thing he's a little bit later
let me take questions that are coming in
um super zero with a twitch Prime
subscription it says get out and vote
people certainly an important message
and super of zero is twitch subscribers
650 I also want to say thanks to fluked
92 for subscribing with twitch prime
subscriber 651 over at over on YouTube
super chat starting to come in
sony sam tron says thoughts and prayers
from norway yeah it's gonna get ugly
today it's gonna get ugly today and then
also Eric tile says you are missing
zalenski no pressure I don't know what
that I exactly know what that means but
I appreciate the super chat
if you have questions or comments for me
by all means send them in via super chat
let me say some thank yous from
subscribers that signed up yesterday I
don't want to miss let's see here
Jeremy Mullen is new member number 154 I
also want to say thanks to Jelani Fraser
who is number 155 and Edward Lefou is
number 156 156 the target for today is
175 new members as you see up there the
coupon code impeach 50 saves you 50% and
it moves the blue bar and it gets me to
say your name and thank you right away
I see a lot of people on the chat who
are excited about seeing the
presentation by Donald Trump's attorney
Jay Sekulow I'm excited for it as well
and I listen we know what they are going
to do they are going to talk about
everything other than Donald Trump's
actual conduct they will try to sort of
circumstantially defend what Donald
Trump did under the guise of being
concerned about corruption and remember
when there's no back-and-forth they can
just put together a case that says that
the phone call was perfect and Trump's
concerned about corruption and that
there's nothing to see here and they may
well get away with it when we have
questions from senators maybe that
narrative will be will be challenged
oair I see erektile says we are missing
zalenski from the bingo chart I see yeah
and the bingo chart is kind of just a
joke I mean the zelinsky's name
obviously is going to come up but these
are the things I imagine Trump's defense
team specifically is going to focus on
because they appear at least two to
exonerate Donald Trump let's look at a
couple other of his recent tweets he's
actually been tweeting all morning
starting with the great Lou Dobbs people
know after three years of this president
the most historic president in our
country's history
that's a me there is it is meaningless
it is linguistically meaningless to say
the most historic president just means
nothing the most historic president in
our country's history that there is no
one who can touch what he's done in
three years foreign policy domestic
policy you name it it's amazing just to
have the guts not to be intimidated by
this national left-wing media that
reduces most politicians and most public
figures - whining crying puddles of
cowardice it is really something to have
a man in the White House who has a
courageous heart and does what he says
he will do I like president Trump's
tweets I like everything about him and
this Ukraine stuff the trial the
impeachment this isn't about Ukraine
Donald Trump has committed the two
unpardonable sins in the eyes of
Democrats he beat Hillary Clinton in
2016 and secondly he is fulfilling every
promise he made what about the ball wall
what about health health care what about
trade what about the deficit well I mean
these are lies and that is making
opponents apoplectic let's see maybe
I'll just reply or retweet with comment
what about the wall deficit debt health
care what else should I include in this
tweet what else did he promise that he
has failed to do Oh
ending America being a laughingstock
ah Muslim ban now I'm going to keep that
out trade war what else do we have
endless wars yeah that one's more
complicated I think they would argue
that he's ending them even though he's
actually threatening even more Wars all
right this is probably good all right we
will retweet there so we are standing by
we are just just a few minutes about ten
minutes away presumably from the start
today I will take questions via super
chat and via twitch subscription
messages sony sam tron says bingo is no
joke bingo is extremely serious bingo is
extremely serious let me thank a couple
of other new members at join pakman.com
William hell avi William Helvey is new
member number 157 Wow we're rapidly
heading towards today's goal of 175
William Helvey is new member and
1:57 joseph aaron's Dorf is new member
number 158 Simon Ray's is new member
number 159 thank you so much we are at
159 members the coupon code impeach 50
saves you 50% off of the membership of
your choice not my choice your choice at
join pakman.com I invite you to head
over and sign up we are we are entering
our what hour is this of impeachment
streams we did let me know Tuesday it
was like 6
Wednesday and Thursday was 8 and 8 16 6
is 22 yesterday was about 1:00 12:30 to
7:30 that's 7 that's 29 so we are in our
30 we are in our 30 actually of
impeachment streams and then the number
one way to support them of course
particularly weekend streams is grabbing
a membership at join pakman.com Eric
tile comes in out of nowhere with a
super chat when the right here's an
indefensible fact they adopt it
contorted and try and muddy the waters
it's actually textbook gaslighting it is
it's it's textbook gas lighting and it's
also how a legal defense is done right
you don't even address points by your
opposition that our adverse that are not
good points for you to be addressing you
reframe the ones you want to address to
be favorable to you and then you add out
of context information on top of that
CBD 1 2 3 says already a member but
wanted to send some more love your way
thank you for all the work you do
especially with all these live streams
love you man thank you and I appreciate
your support CBD I remember you've been
super chatting for a few days and I I do
appreciate that
welcome to Marika L Marika has been here
I think almost every day thanks for the
bingo you forgot read the transcript
that's right okay so let me actually
make a note if I can let me see how to
do this I'm going to do when they get
started I'll do an updated transcript
and maybe it'll be a four by four so I
need to add
szalinski I'm just making notes let me
know in the chat what else should be
added here read the transcript what else
am I missing from the transcript on my
Twitter page from the bingo card rather
that we are likely to hear today from
the from Trump's lawyers lawyer lawsuits
is on there I see a lot of people saying
lawyer lawsuits but that's there
there definitely should be more othor t
fat well Hillary's emails 30,000 emails
is sort of part of it maybe I'll just
update it to say Hillary's 30k emails I
do like that oh Sh if t well we're not
gonna hear shift e shift we're not gonna
hear shifty shift no crimes
yeah no crimes I would be surprised if
we didn't hear anything else that I need
to include investigate the Biden yeah
Biden is already on there so that kind
of covers all of the Biden stuff Oh
lethal aid yeah lethal aid absolutely we
are going to hear that's a good one so
we have 916
yeah we've basically got enough for a
four by four right now perfect phone
call is on there Biden's is on there
no no are saying a lot of things Trump
is going to say our question is what are
Trump's lawyers going to say Oh overturn
election overturn election that's
another argument they are going to make
that this is all in an attempt to
overturn the election what about I don't
know about that you need 7 for a 4 by 4
molar medical amount of water now we're
not going to hear that Oh basement yeah
basement hearings that's a good one that
all of these hearings supposedly took
place in the hearings secret basement
hearings I would actually add one two
three four five six okay I think that
that'll get us to four by four and with
one extra so I'll put together and you
won't follow me on twitter at D Pakman
as soon as they start I will put
together a new one and then I will I
we'll tweet it out and I think it'll be
it'll be enjoyable for all of us oh wait
due process yeah did I have that on due
process is a good one we might actually
get enough for a five by five the way
things were going
hamburgers we will probably hear yeah
Oh duly elected duly elected we might
here yeah these are good hunter Biden is
part of that yeah Biden covers all of
that Parnas no unfair process Russian
hoax Russian hoax we might hear ya
witch-hunt kind of covers that okay good
overturning an election is being
suggested by a lot of people and yeah
we're definitely that's on the list
already and we're definitely going to
hear that okay let's see here other
super to actually hold on first of all
let me see if I have any other members
to thank oh I don't that's sad our goal
is 175 but we're sort of stuck right now
at 159 okay let me go over to on twitch
I want to say thanks to Lubow the one
for subscribing with twitch Prime you
are twitch prime subscriber number 655
655 I very much appreciate that
super chats continue to come in a
William Hinkle has become a soy boy by
subscribing on YouTube I appreciate that
EDD says when yang dropps who will his
supporters go to you know unfortunately
the good thing about engaging a lot of
new people as Andrew yang has done is
that you're engaging new people the bad
thing is when he drops they may not vote
at all and that's that's that would be
scary to me but hopefully I have a
feeling Andrew yang will do the right
thing and will say to people you've got
to vote for the Democratic nominee to
remove Trump a so nice and Sam Tron says
dinner at 6:30 no so today they actually
it's only a three hour session today
expect it to go just from 10:00 a.m. to
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time and so there will
be no dinner break there may not even be
a break at all it may just be a
two-and-a-half hour overview from Jay
Sekulow
and then that that might be it erektile
wants they were wrong about Russia on
the bingo card I've got some versions of
that
Shayne Vaness suggests that there will
be seeking apologies for things oh wait
a second crowd strike crowd strike
should be on there crowd strike that's a
good one yeah I'm gonna put this updated
one together and I think that that's uh
I think that that'll be very we're
looking at that very very strongly let
me say thanks to heavily broken one who
has subscribed with twitch Prime and his
twitch subscriber 656 six five six thank
you so much we're getting dangerously
close to 666 twitch subscribers and I
think that more than likely when we do
that absolutely nothing will happen
because it's just a number we are just a
couple of minutes up to 15 minutes maybe
from the start of the Donald Trump
attorneys defending Donald Trump Donald
Trump has been extremely extremely
active on Twitter today let's see if he
sent anything else so far nope so he
sent so far this morning one two three
four five tweets and I guess actually
some of these retweets may have taped
but taken place this morning as well
tweeting a lot of propaganda from
various various Republicans I anticipate
particularly being a Saturday that Trump
is going to be very very busy very very
busy on Twitter today let me say thanks
to in eighty eight fingers for the
twitch Prime subscription subscriber 657
with the message any thoughts on Warren
being Bernie's running mate at any point
in the near future you know before the
dust-up with Bernie and Warren and the
Bernie said a woman can't win thing I
actually would have thought that
Elizabeth Warren was a very plausible
running mate for Bernie Sanders or vice
versa I don't really see it anymore
particularly after after what happened I
just don't imagine that that is going to
be something that we see um Keith Stone
says via super chat how about partisan
impeachment in the in the the bingo card
that could work if we need to fill
another one
Alejandro Sanchez says hey Pakman love
the content constant streams anyway was
the Russia probe really as much of a
witch-hunt as Trump says it was weren't
people incarcerated yeah it was a
witch-hunt that found like 35 witches to
indict and prove wronged wrongdoing
about with evidence so yeah what does it
really mean that it was a witch hunt at
this point an increasingly meaningless
increasingly meaningless phrase I see
people joining us and confused isn't it
Saturday what is going on is they're
really going to be trial today there is
they are doing a three-hour session a
Mitch McConnell said they would be going
six days a week for as long as they need
to today is day one of Donald Trump's
attorneys presenting their case and we
are going to hear from Jay Sekulow and
Pat Cipollone E and I think we all know
what to expect if you're just joining us
please follow me on twitter where we
have a trump lawyer bingo card of what
we expect to hear we got a bunch of new
suggestions from viewers and I'm going
to be expanding the bingo card and
posting it to my twitter as soon as this
starts I will move over to my computer
and put together a more extensive bingo
card so make sure you're following me
there over on Twitch the hype train is
here and we've only won successfully
completed hype train level 5 but the
hype train is happening I want to say
thanks to captain red for subscribing
with prime you are twitch subscriber 658
658 I want to say thank you to one other
new member who has signed up at join
pakman.com and that is Dean Melton Dean
Melton is new member number one six zero
you will see the bar move up just
slightly
there it goes just slightly we have a
goal today of 175 subscribers at join
pakman.com coupon code impeach 50 the
website memberships are the most direct
way and the most reliable way that don't
depend on any of these other platforms
to support the work that we do including
the 30th hour of impeachment streams
which we are entering right now consider
sign
at join pakman.com as they're about to
get started here let me say oh thanks to
pare tearin' who comes in with a hundred
Swedish kronor super chat not to be
nitty picky but the number correctly
translated is six one six BR / PE are
number correctly translated is six once
I have no idea what pair is talking
about parrot we love you and you've been
a great supporter but I don't know what
you're talking about the correctly
translated number is six one six I don't
know what that means the euphy Oh answer
says does Bernie consider Gabbard for VP
to have a woman I don't think so I don't
think I don't think that he does I will
be continuing to mute the prayer during
these opening sessions because I believe
in separation of church and state and
think it's ridiculous to have a
religious prayer at the beginning of the
impeachment trial of a president you see
Jay Sekulow here sort of bumbling around
and getting ready to present his case
over here we have the chaplain this
gentleman typically wearing a bowtie oh
I looked quickly and it almost looked
like this guy had his hands wrapped
around this woman but if they were her
hands that were just kind of crossed
Adam Schiff has entered the chamber how
came Jeffrey's is over here so people
are people are starting to filter in
Keith stone says one more suggestion
mentions of the trial as we see more
senators arrived again the the video we
get is from the US Senate the video and
audio the table on the left is that for
the house managers they've finished
presenting their case Hakeem Jeffries
Jason Crowe coming into the room the
president's defense team is on the table
on the right in that table is a pretty
full right now as we await the arrival
of the Chief Justice to begin the
proceeding yep so you've got I just saw
there's Val Demings coming in this is I
believe this is a the Democratic Council
Daniel Goldman is it I believe his name
was if I'm thinking back now to the days
of the of the hearings before the House
panels a lot happening a lot
happening for sure um let's see I want
to say thanks to axis TV for subscribing
with one month at tier one twitch
subscriber 658 also I want to say thanks
to I cover myself in Nutella for
cheering at 483 bits as well as
political puppy for cheering two hundred
bits thanks very much appreciate it
we are presumably just minutes minutes
from the start of Donald Trump's defense
team making their case making their case
for Donald Trump's acquittal which I
continue to believe is a foregone
conclusion at this point in time and I
think it is certainly bound to happen
unless something completely unforeseen
were to take place we probably have
somewhere between you know two and ten
minutes until they get started if
anybody else has any questions or
comments via super chat on YouTube they
will pop up on the screen and I will
answer your questions any questions or
comments coming in via twitch
subscriptions will show up up there as
John Roberts comes in we will listen to
him but again I will be muting the
prayer beam as a court of impeachment
the chaplain will lead us in prayer okay
and we mute that again
we shouldn't have prayers prayers
shouldn't be part of this this is a
government that claims to have
separation of church and state we
shouldn't be doing a prayer to God
before evidence is presented about the
impeachment of the president so we've
we've been muting that and we just
aren't going to listen to it my friends
we're just not going to listen to it
fear not any messages super chats
membership subscriptions anything that
happens during the long sessions that
they will be running I will get to after
during during the next break and as I
mentioned I will be updating the Trump
lawyer bingo card on my Twitter page at
D Pakman as soon as they're done I'll go
ahead and get a new one tweeted and then
you you can you'll be able to find it on
my Twitter page they will also after
this be doing the Pledge of Allegiance
which we also have been muting it all
feels just like nonsense it I don't
think we need it that's the thing I
don't think it furthers our
understanding of what's
going on here one bit and John Roberts
with his head lowered in prayer of
course Daniel Huberman says what about
the head on a pike comment oh I don't
I miss that I don't know what that is
head on a pike I'm not sure what that is
radical left we should have on the bingo
card radical left so I will add that
that'll be a good one
political puppy says religion fine
unless it goes overboard
this is overboard other countries don't
do this yeah we shouldn't have we
shouldn't be having a Christian prayer
before the president's impeachment
proceedings Cassie Bates says how much
do you think acquittal affects the
future of government it I think it will
affect it we just don't know exactly to
what degree but I think for sure there
what everything that is happening that
that has already happened whether or not
Donald Trump is acquitted is going to
have an effect on future US government
for sure alright looks like they are
going to get started now senators please
be seated
we may hear from Mitch McConnell about
the schedule first day there is no
objection the journal of proceedings of
the trial are approved to date the
sergeant at arms will make the
proclamation low energy sergeant at arms
here Harry Harry Harry all persons are
commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment well the Senate of the
United States sitting for the trial of
the articles of impeachment exhibited by
the House of Representatives against
Donald John Trump President of the
United States a majority leader is
recognized
colleagues we should expect two to three
hours of session today we'll take a
quick break if needed
as expected pursuant to the provisions
of Senate resolution 483 the counsel for
the president have 24 hours to make the
presentation of their case the Senate
will now hear you
here we go citing officer recognizes mr.
Sibal oniy to begin presentation of the
case for the president Cipollone es
starting as we expected
Thank You mr. chief justice
senators leader McConnell Democratic
leader Schumer thank you for your time
and thank you for your attention I want
to start out just very briefly giving
you a short plan for today we we're
going to be very respectful of your time
as leader McConnell said we anticipate
going about two to three hours at most
and to be out of here by one o'clock at
the latest we're going to focus today on
two points you heard the house managers
speak for nearly 24 hours over three
days we don't anticipate using that much
time we don't believe that they have
come anywhere close to meeting their
burden for what they're asking you to do
in fact we believe that when you hear
the facts and that's what we intend to
cover today the facts you will find that
the president did absolutely nothing
wrong
and what we intend to do today and we'll
have more presentations in greater
detail on Monday but what we intend to
do today is go through their record that
they established in the house and we
intend to show you some of the evidence
that they adduced in the house that they
decided over there three days and 24
hours that they didn't have enough time
or made a decision not to show you and
every time you see one of these pieces
of evidence ask yourself why didn't I
see that in the first three days they
had it it came out of their process why
didn't they show that to the Senate and
I think that's an important question
because as house managers really their
goal should be to give you all of the
facts because they're asking you to do
something very very consequential and I
would submit to you to use a word that
mr. Schiff used a lot very very
dangerous and that's the second point
that I'd ask you to keep in mind today
they're asking you not only to overturn
the results of the last election but as
I've said before they're asking you to
remove President Trump from the ballot
in an election that's occurring in
approximately nine months they're asking
you to tear up all of the ballots across
this country on your own initiative take
that decision away from the American
people and I don't think they spent one
minute of their 24 hours talking to you
about the consequences of that for our
country not one minute they didn't tell
you what that would mean for our country
today this year and forever into our
future they're asking you to do
something that no Senate has ever done
and they're asking you to do it with no
evidence and that's wrong and I ask you
to keep that in mind I ask you to keep
that in mind so what I would do is point
out one piece of evidence for you and
then I'm going to turn it over to my
colleagues and they will walk you
through their record and they will show
you things that they didn't show you now
they didn't talk a lot about the
transcript of the call which I would
submit is the best evidence of what
happened on the
all and they said things over and over
again that are simply not true one of
them was there's no evidence of
president Trump's interest in
burden-sharing that wasn't the real
reason but they didn't tell you that
burden-sharing
was discussed in the call in the
transcript of the call they didn't tell
you that why let me read it to you
here's the president and we'll go
through the entire transcript I'm not
going to read the whole transcript we'll
make it available I'm sure you have it
but we'll make available copies of the
transcript so you can have it the
president said and they read this line I
will say that we do a lot for Ukraine we
spend a lot of effort and a lot of time
but they stopped there they didn't read
the following much more than European
countries are doing and they should be
helping you more than they are Germany
does almost nothing for you all they do
is talk and I think it's something that
you should really ask them about when I
was speaking to Angela Merkel she talks
Ukraine but she doesn't do anything a
lot of European countries are the same
way so I think it's something you want
to look at but the United States has
been very very good to Ukraine that's
where they that's where they picked up
again with the quote but they left out
the entire discussion a burden-sharing
now what is president Solinsky say does
he disagree
no he agrees they didn't tell you this
didn't tell you this didn't have time in
24 hours to tell you this yes you are
absolutely right not only 100% but
actually 100% and I can tell you the
following I did talk to Angela Merkel
and I did meet with her and I also met
and talked with McCrone and I told them
that they are not doing quite as much as
they need to be doing on the issues with
the sanctions they are not enforcing the
sanctions they are not working as much
as they should work for Ukraine it turns
out that even though logically the
European Union should be our should be
our biggest partner but technically the
United States is a much bigger partner
than the European Union and I'm very
grateful to you for that because the
United States is doing quite a lot for
Ukraine much more than the European
Union especially when we are talking
about sanctions against the Russian
Federation you heard a lot about the
importance of confronting Russia and
we're going to talk about that and you
will hear that President Trump has a
strong record on confronting Russia you
will hear that President Trump has a
strong record of support for Ukraine you
will hear that from the witnesses in
their record that they didn't tell you
about
so that's one very important example
they come here to the Senate and they
ask you remove a president tear up the
ballots in all of your states and they
don't bother to read the key evidence of
the discussion of burden-sharing
that's in the call itself now that's
emblematic of their entire presentation
I'm going to turn the presentation over
to my colleague Mike purpura he's going
to walk you through many more examples
of this and with each example ask
yourself why am I just hearing about
this now after 24 hours of sitting
through arguments why and the reason is
we can talk about the process we will
talk about the law but today we are
going to confront them on the merits of
their argument now they have the burden
of proof
and they have not come close to meeting
it in fact and I want to ask you to
think about one issue regarding process
beyond process if you were really
interested in finding out the truth why
would you run a process the way they ran
if you were really confident in your
position on the facts why would you lock
everybody out of it from the president's
side why would you do that we will talk
about the process arguments but the
process arguments also are compelling
evidence on the merits because it's
evidence that they themselves don't
believe in the facts of their case and
the fact that they came here for 24
hours and hid evidence from you is
further evidence that they don't really
believe in the facts of their case that
this is for all their talk about
election interference that they're here
to perpetrate the most massive
interference in an election in American
history and we can't allow that to
happen it would violate our Constitution
it would violate our history it would
violate our obligations to the future
and most importantly it would violate
the sacred trust that the American
people have placed in you and have
placed in them the American people
decide elections they have one coming up
in nine months
so we will be very efficient we will
begin our presentation today we will
show you a lot of evidence that they
should have showed you and we will
finish efficiently and quickly so that
we can all go have an election thank you
and I yield to my colleague Michael
purpura mr. chief justice
members of the Senate good morning again
my name is Michael purpura I serve as
deputy counsel to the president it is my
honor and privilege to appear before you
today on behalf of prized president
Donald J Trump and what is the
president's response well it reads like
a classic organized crime shakedown
shorn of its rambling character and in
not so many words this is the essence of
what the president communicates we've
been very good to your country very good
no other country has done as much as we
have but you know what I don't see much
reciprocity here I hear what you want I
have a favor I want from you though and
I'm gonna say this only seven times so
you better listen good I want you to
make up dirt on my political opponent
understand lots of it on this and on
that I'm gonna put you in touch with
people and not just any people I'm gonna
put you in touch with Attorney General
the United States my attorney general
bill Barr he's got the whole weight of
the American law enforcement behind him
and I'm gonna put you in touch with Rudy
you're gonna love him trust me
you know what I'm asking and so I'm only
gonna say this a few more times in a few
more ways and by the way don't call me
again
I'll call you when you've done what I
asked this is in sum and character what
the president was trying to communicate
that's fake
that's not the real call that's not the
evidence here that's not the transcript
that mr. Sibal Oni
just referenced and we can shrug it off
and say we were making light or a joke
but that was in a hearing in the United
States House of Representatives
discussing the removal of the President
of the United States from office there
are very few things if any that can be
as grave and as serious let's stick with
the evidence let's talk about the facts
and the evidence in this case the most
important piece of evidence we have in
the case and before you is the one that
we began with nearly four months ago the
actual transcript of the July 25 2019
telephone call between President Trump
and President Solinsky the real
transcript if that were the only
evidence we had it would be enough to
show that the Democrats entire theory is
completely unfounded but the transcript
is far from the only evidence
demonstrating that the president did
nothing wrong once you sweep away all of
the bluster and innuendo the selective
leaks the closed-door examinations of
the Democrats hand-picked witnesses the
staged public hearings what we're left
with are six key facts that have not and
will not change
first the transcript shows that the
president did not condition either
security assistance or a meeting on
anything
the paused security assistance funds
aren't even mentioned on the call second
president zalenski and other Ukrainian
officials have repeatedly said that
there was no quid pro quo and no
pressure on them to review anything
third president Solinsky and
high-ranking Ukrainian officials did not
even know did not even know the security
assistance was paused until the end of
August over a month after the July 25
call forth not a single witness
testified that the President himself
said that there was any connection
between any investigations and security
assistance a presidential meeting or
anything else fifth the security
assistance flowed on September 11 and a
presidential meeting took place on
September 25 without the Ukrainian
government announcing any investigations
finally the Democrats blind drive to
impeach the president does not and
cannot change the fact as attested to by
the Democrats own witnesses that
President Trump has been a better friend
and stronger supporter of Ukraine than
his predecessor those are the facts we
plan to address some of them today and
some of them next week each one of these
six facts standing alone is enough to
sink the Democrats case combined they
establish what we've known since the
beginning the president did absolutely
nothing wrong the Democrats allegation
that the president engaged in a quid pro
quo is unfounded and contrary to the
facts the truth is simple and it's right
before our eyes the president was at all
times acting in our national interest
and pursuant to his oath of office but
before I dive in and speak further about
the facts let me mention something that
my colleagues will discuss in greater
detail the facts that I'm about to
discuss today are the Democrats facts
this is important because the house
managers spoke to you for a very long
time over 21 hours and have repeatedly
claimed to you that their case is in
their evidence is overwhelming and
uncontested it's not I'm going to share
a number of facts with you this morning
that the house managers didn't share
with you during more than 21 hours I'll
ask you as mr. sip baloney already
mentioned that when you hear me say
something that the house managers didn't
present to you ask yourself why didn't
they tell me that is that something I
would have liked to have known why am i
hearing it for the first time from the
president's lawyers it's not because
they didn't have enough time that's for
sure
they only showed you a very selective
part of the record their record and they
remember this they have the very heavy
burden of proof before you the president
is forced to mount a defense in this
chamber against a record that the
Democrats developed the record that we
have to go on today is based entirely on
House Democratic facts pre-cleared in a
break in a basement bunker not mostly
entirely
yet even those facts absolutely
exonerate the president let's start with
the transcript the president did not
link security assistance to any
investigations on the July 25 call let's
step back on July 25 President Trump
called president zalenski this was their
second phone call
both were congratulatory on April 21st
President Trump called to congratulate
President Solinsky on winning the
presidential election on July 25 the
president called because President
zelinsky's party had just won a large
number of seats in parliament on
September 24 before speaker Pelosi had
any idea what President Trump and
president Solinsky actually said on the
July 25 call she called for an
impeachment inquiry into President Rama
in the interest of full transparency and
to show that he had done nothing wrong
president Trump took the unprecedented
unprecedented step of declassifying to
call transcript so that the American
people could see for themselves exactly
what the two presidents discussed so
what did President Trump say to
President zalenski on the July 25 call
president Trump raised two issues I'm
going to be speaking about those two
issues a fair amount this morning there
are the two issues that go to the core
of how President Trump approaches
foreign aid when it comes to sending US
taxpayer money overseas the president is
focused on burden sharing and corruption
first the president rightly had real
concerns about whether European in other
countries were contributing their fair
share to ensuring Ukraine's security
second corruption since the fall of the
Soviet Union Ukraine has suffered from
one of the worst environments for
corruption in the world a parade of
witnesses testified in the house about
the pervasive corruption in Ukraine and
how it is in America's foreign policy
and national security interests to help
Ukraine combat corruption
turning the call right off the bat
President Trump mentioned burden-sharing
to president zalenski
president Trump told president szalinski
that Germany does almost nothing for you
and a lot of European countries are the
same way President Trump specifically
mentioned speaking to Angela Merkel of
Germany whom he said talks Ukraine but
she doesn't do anything
president zalenski agreed you are
absolutely right he said that he spoke
with the leaders of Jerk of Germany and
France and told them that they are not
doing quite as much as they need to be
doing so right at the beginning of the
call president Trump was talking about
burden-sharing
president Trump then turned to
corruption in the form of foreign
interference in the 2016 presidential
election there is absolutely nothing
wrong with asking a foreign leader to
help get to the bottom of all forms of
foreign interference in American
presidential election you'll hear more
about that later from one of my
colleagues what else did the president
say the president also warned president
Solinsky that he appeared to be
surrounding himself with some of the
same people as his predecessor and
suggested that a very fair and very good
prosecutor was shut down by some very
bad people again one of my colleagues
will speak more about that the content
of the July 25 call was in line with the
Trump administration's legitimate
concerns about corruption and reflected
the hope that President Solinsky who
campaigned on a platform of reform would
finally clean up Ukraine so what the
president Trump and president szalinski
discussed in the July 25 call to issues
burden-sharing
corruption just as importantly what
wasn't discussed on the July 25 call
there was no discussion of the paused
Security Assistance on the July 25 call
house Democrats keep pointing to
presidents Lenski statement that I would
also like to thank you for your great
support in the area of defense but he
wasn't talking there about the pause
security assistance
he tells us in the very next sentence
exactly what he was talking about
javelin missiles we already president
zalenski continues to continue to
cooperate for the next steps
specifically we are almost ready to buy
more javelins from the United States for
defense purposes javelins are the
anti-tank missiles only made available
to the Ukrainians by President Trump
President Obama refused to give javelins
to the Ukrainians for years javelin
sales were not part were not part of the
security assistance that had been paused
at the time of the call javelins sales
have nothing to do with the pause
security assistance those are different
programs entirely but don't take my word
for it both former ambassador to Ukraine
Murray Ivanovich an NSC senior director
Timothy Morrison confirmed that the
javelin missiles and the security
assistance were unrelated the house
managers didn't tell you about
ambassador Jovanovic is and Tim
Morrison's testimony why not they could
have taken two to five minutes out of 21
hours to make sure you understood that
the javelin sails being discussed were
not part of the pause security
assistance this puts the following
statement by President Trump in a whole
new light doesn't it I would like you to
do us a favor though because our country
has been through a lot and Ukraine knows
a lot about it as everyone knows by now
President Trump asked President Solinsky
to do us a favor and he made clear that
us referred to our country and not
himself more importantly the president
was not connecting
do us a favor to the javelin sales the
president's Lenski mentioned it makes no
sense in that in the language there but
even if he had been the javelin sales
were not part of his security assistance
that had been temporarily paused I want
to be very clear about this when the
House Democrats claim that the javelins
sales discussed on the July 25 call are
part of the pause security assistance it
is misleading they are trying to confuse
you and just sort of wrap everything in
instead of
unpacking it the right way there was no
mention of the pause security assistance
on the call and certainly not from
President Trump as you know head of
state calls are staffed by a number of
aides on both sides
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN man to
detailee at the National Security
Council raised a concern about the call
and that was just a policy concern
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh admitted
that he did not know whether there was a
crime or anything of that nature but he
had deep policy concerns policy concerns
so there you have it but the president
the president sets the foreign policy in
a democracy such as ours the elected
leaders make foreign policy while the
unelected staff such as
lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh implement
the policy other witnesses were on the
July 25 call and had very different
reactions than that of Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh Lieutenant General
Keith Kellogg national security advisor
the vice president former acting
national security advisor in a
long-serving and highly decorated
veteran attended to call according to
General Kellogg I was on the much
reported July 25 call between President
Donald Trump and President Zielinski as
an exceedingly proud member of the Trump
administration of President trumps
administration and as a 34 year highly
experienced combat veteran who retired
with the rank of lieutenant-general in
the Army I heard nothing wrong or
improper on the call I had and have no
concerns the house managers said that
other witnesses were also troubled by
the July 25 call and identified those
witnesses as Jennifer Williams and Tim
Morrison Jennifer Williams who works for
Lieutenant General Kellogg now claims
that she has concerns about the call you
heard that from the house managers they
were very careful in the way they worded
that
what they didn't tell you is that miss
Williams was so troubled at the time of
the call that she told exactly zero
people of her concern she told no one
for two months following the call
not one person Ms Williams didn't raise
any concerns about the call when it took
place
not with Lieutenant General Kellogg not
with Council not with anyone Ms Williams
waited to announce her concerns until
speaker Pelosi publicly announced her
impeachment inquiry the house managers
didn't tell you that why not
Tim Morrison who is Lieutenant Colonel
VIN moons boss was also on the call Mr
Morrison reported the call to the
National Security Council lawyers not
because he was troubled by anything on
the call but because he was worried
about leaks and in his words how it
would play out in Washington's polarized
environment I want to be clear mr.
Morrison testified I was not concerned
that anything illegal was discussed Mr
Morrison further testified that there
was nothing improper and nothing illegal
about anything that was said on the call
in fact mr. Morrison repeatedly
testified that he disagreed with
lieutenant-colonel VIN moons assessment
that President Trump made demands of
President zolensky or that he said
anything improper at all here's mr.
Morrison in that transcript does the
president not ask Solinsky to look into
the Biden's mr. chairman I can only tell
you what I was thinking at the time that
is not what I understood the president
to be doing do you believe in your
opinion that the president knighted
States demanded the president Solinsky
undertake these investigations no sir
and you didn't hear the president make a
demand did you no sir again there were
no demands from your perspective mr.
Morrison that is correct sir but is it
fair to say that as you were listening
to the call you weren't thinking while
the president's president is bribing the
president of Ukraine that never crossed
your mind it did not sir or that he was
extorting the president of Ukraine
doing anything improper correct sir
significantly the Ukrainian government
never raised any concerns about the July
25 call just hours after the call
ambassador William Taylor head of the US
mission in Ukraine had dinner with then
the then secretary of the Ukrainian
National Security and Defense Council
who seemed to think that the call went
fine the call went well he wasn't
disturbed by anything the house managers
didn't tell you that why not
ambassador Kurt Volker the US Special
Representative for Ukraine was not on
the call but ambassador Volcker spoke
regularly with presidents Lenski and
other top officials in the Ukraine
government and even met with President
zalenski the day after the call he
testified that in no way shape or form
in either the readouts from the United
States or Ukraine did he receive any
indication whatsoever for anything that
resembles a quid pro quo on the July 25
call
here's ambassador Volcker and in fact
the day after the call you met with
President Solinsky this would be on July
26 that's good and in that meeting he
made no mention of quid pro quo no he
made no mention of withholding the aid
no he made no mention of bribery no so
the fact is the Ukrainians were not even
aware of this hold on aid is that
correct that's correct
they didn't tell you about this
testimony from ambassador Volker why not
president Solinsky himself has confirmed
on at least three separate occasions
that his July 25 call with President
Trump was a good phone call and normal
and that nobody pushed me when president
solinsky's advisor Andre your Mac was
asked if he had ever felt there was a
connection between the US military aid
in the request for investigations he was
adamant that we never had that feeling
and we did not have the feeling that
this aide was connected to any one
specific issue of course the best
evidence that there was no pressure or
quid pro quo is the statements of the
Ukrainians themselves the fact that
President Solinsky himself felt no
pressure on the call and did not
perceive there to be any connection
between security assistance and
investigations would in any ordinary
case in any court be totally fatal to
the prosecution the judge would throw it
out the case would be over what more do
you need to know the house team knows
that they know the record inside out
upside down left and right so what do
they do how do they try to overcome the
direct words from President Solinsky and
his administration that they felt no
pressure they tell you that the
Ukrainians must have felt pressure
regardless of what they've said they try
to overcome the devastating evidence
against them by apparently claiming to
be mind reader's they know what's in
president zelinsky's mind better than
president zalenski does president
Solinsky said he felt no pressure the
house managers tell you they know better
and this is really a theme of the house
case I want you to remember this every
time the Democrats say that President
Trump made demands or issued a quid pro
quo to President Solinsky on the July 25
call they are saying the president
zalenski
and his top advisers are being
untruthful and they acknowledge what
that's what the
saying they've set it over the past few
days tell me how that helps tell me how
that helps us foreign policy and
national security to say that about our
friends we know there was no quid pro
quo on the call we know that from the
transcript but the call is not the only
evidence showing that there was no quid
pro quo there couldn't possibly have
been a quid pro quo because the
Ukrainians did not even know that the
Security Assistance was on hold until it
was reported in the media by Politico at
the end of August more than a month
after the July 25 call think about this
the Democrats accused the president of
leveraging security assistance to
supposedly force President Solinsky to
announce investigations but how can that
possibly be when the Ukrainians were not
even aware that the Security Assistance
was paused there can't be a threat
without the person knowing he's being
threatened there can't be a quid pro quo
without the quo ambassador Volcker
testified that the Ukrainians did not
know about the hold until reading about
it in Politico ambassador Taylor and Tim
Morrison both agreed Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State George Kent testified
that no Ukrainian official contacted him
about the paused security assistance
until that first intense week in
September let's hear from the four of
them I believe the Ukrainians became
aware of the hold on August 29th and not
before that date is the first time any
of them asked me about the hold by
forwarding an article that had been
published in Politico it was only after
August 29th when the political argument
that I got calls from the from several
of the Ukrainian officials you mentioned
the August 28th Politico article was
that the first time that you believed
the Ukrainians may have had a real sense
that the aid was yes mr. Kent
had you had in a Ukrainian official
contacting you concern
about when was the first time a
Ukrainian official contacted you
concerned about potential withholding of
USA it was after the article and
political came out in that first intense
week of September it wasn't until the
Politico article that that's correct I
received a text message from one of my
Ukrainian counterparts on August 29th
forwarding that article and that's the
first they raised it with me the house
managers didn't show you this testimony
from any of these four witnesses why not
why didn't they give you the context of
this testimony and think about this as
well if the Ukrainians had been aware of
the review on security assistance they
of course would have said something
there were numerous high-level
diplomatic meetings between senior
Ukrainian and US officials during the
summer after the review on the Security
Assistance began but before President
zalenski learned of the hold through the
political article if the Ukrainians had
known about the hold they would have
raised it in one of those meetings yet
the Ukrainians didn't say anything about
the hold at a single one of those
meetings not on July 9 not on July 10
not on July 25 not on July 26 not on
August 27 at none of those meetings
none of those meetings did the
Ukrainians mention the pause on security
assistance ambassador Volcker testified
that he was regularly in touch with the
senior highest level officials in the
Ukrainian government and Ukrainian
officials would confide things and would
have asked if they had any questions
about the aid nobody said a word to
ambassador Volcker until the end of
August
then within hours of the political
article being published mr. uremic
texted ambassador Volker with a link to
the article and to ask about the report
in other words as soon as the Ukrainians
learned about the hold they asked about
it
now mr. Schiff said something during the
21 hours or more than 21 hours that he
and his team spoke that I actually agree
with which is when he talked about
common sense many of us at the tables
and in the room are former prosecutors
at the state federal or military level
prosecutors talk a lot about common
sense common sense comes into play right
here the top Ukrainian officials said
nothing nothing at all
to their US counterparts during all of
these meetings about the pause on
security assistance but then BOOM soon
as the political article comes out
suddenly in that first intense week of
September in George Kent's words
security assistance was all they wanted
to talk about what must me conclude if
we're using our common sense that they
didn't know about the pause until the
political article on August 28th no
activity before article comes out flurry
of activity that's common sense and it's
absolutely fatal to the house managers
case the house managers are aware that
the Ukrainians lack of knowledge on the
hold is fatal to their case and so
they've desperately tried to muddy the
water the manner just told you the
Deputy Assistant Secretary of Defense
Laura Cooper presented to me two emails
two emails that people on her staff
received from people at the State
Department regarding conversations with
people at the Ukraine Embassy that could
have been about us security assistance
to Ukraine what they did not tell you is
that ms cooper testified that she could
not say for certain whether the emails
were about the pause on security
assistance she couldn't say one way or
the other she also testified that she
didn't want to speculate about the
meaning of the words in the emails the
house managers also didn't tell you
miss Cooper testified that I reviewed my
calendar and the only meet
where I can recall when Ukrainian
official raising the issue of security
assistance with me is on September 5th
at the Ukrainian Independence Day
celebration the house managers didn't
tell you that the house managers also
mentioned that one of ambassador Volkers
one of ambassador Volkers advisors
Catherine Croft claimed that the
Ukrainian embassy officials learned
about the pause earlier than the
political article but when asked when
she heard from the ukraine embassy
officials miss Croft admitted that she
can't remember those specifics and did
not think that she took notes miss Croft
also did not remember when news of the
hole became public remember though that
ambassador Volcker her boss who was in
regular contact with President Solinsky
and the top Ukrainian aides was very
clear that I believe the Ukrainians
became aware of the hold on August 29
and not before this is all the house
managers have in contrast to testimony
of Volcker Taylor Morrison and Kent the
text from your Mac the words of the
high-ranking Ukrainians themselves and
the flurry of activity that began on
August 28th and that's the evidence that
they want you to consider as a basis to
remove the duly elected president of the
United States the bottom line is it is
not possible for the brief Security
Assistance Review to have been used as
leverage when President zalenski and
other top Ukrainian officials did not
know about it that's what you need to
know that's what the house managers
didn't tell you the house managers know
how important this issue is when we
briefly mentioned it a few days ago they
told us we needed to check our facts we
did were right
president szalinski 'no stop aides did
not know about the pause on security
assistance at the time of the July 25
call and did not know about it until
August 28th when a political article was
published
we know there was no quid pro quo on the
July 25 call we know the Ukrainians did
not know that security assistance had
been paused at the time of the call
there is simply no evidence anywhere the
president Trump ever linked security
assistance to any investigations most of
the Democrats witnesses have never
spoken to the president at all let alone
about Ukraine security assistance the
two people in the house record who asked
President Trump about whether there was
any linkage between security assistance
and investigations were told in no
uncertain terms that there's no
connection between the two when
ambassador the European Union Gordon
Sandlin
asked the president in approximately the
September 9 timeframe the president told
him I want nothing I want nothing I want
no quid pro quo even earlier on August
31 Senator Ron Johnson asked the
president if there was any connection
between security assistance and
investigations the president answered no
way I would never do that who told you
that two witnesses ambassador Taylor and
Tim Morrison said they came to belief
security assistance was linked to
investigations but both witnesses base
this belief entirely on what they heard
from ambassador sunland before
ambassador Sandlin spoke to the
president neither Taylor no Morse and
ever spoke to the president about the
matter how did ambassador saw and Lynn
come to believe that there was any
connection between security assistance
and investigations again the house
managers didn't tell you why not in his
public testimony ambassador saw inland
used variations of the words assume
presume guests speculate and belief over
30 times here are some examples that was
my presumption my personal presumption
that was my belief that was my
presumption yeah as I said I presume
that might have to be done in order to
get the aid released it was a
presumption I've been very clear as to
when I was
presuming and I was presuming on the aid
it would be pure
you know guesswork on my part
speculation I don't I don't know that
was the problem mr. Goldman no one told
me directly that the aid was tied to
anything
I was presuming it was didn't show you
any of this testimony not once during
their 21 hour presentation
twenty-one hours more than 21 hours and
they couldn't give you the context to
evaluate ambassador Sandow all the
Democrats have to support the alleged
link between security assistance and
investigations is ambassador Solomon's
assumptions and presumptions we remember
this exchange is it correct no one on
this planet told you that Donald Trump
was tying this aid to the investigations
because if your answer is yes then the
Chairman's wrong and the headline on CNN
is wrong no one on this planet told you
that President Trump was tying aid to
investigations yes or no yes so you
really have no testimony today that ties
President Trump to a scheme to withhold
aid from Ukraine in exchange for these
investigations other than my own
presumption when he was done presuming
assuming and guessing ambassador Solomon
finally decided as president Trump
directly what does the president want
from Ukraine here's the answer
President Trump when I asked him the
open-ended question as I testified
previously what do you want from Ukraine
his answer was I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tell zalenski to do the
right thing that's all I got from
President Trump the president was
unequivocal
ambassador saw none stated this was the
final word he heard from the President
of the United States and once he learned
this he text messaged ambassadors Taylor
and Volker the president has been
crystal clear no quid pro quos of any
kind if you are sceptical of ambassador
Cylons testimony it was corroborated by
the statement of one of your colleagues
senator Johnson senator Johnson also had
heard from ambassador Sunland that the
Security Assistance might be linked to
the investigations so on August 31
senator Johnson asked the president
directly
whether there was some kind of
arrangement where Ukraine would take
some action and the hold would be lifted
again president Trump's answer was
crystal clear no way I would never do
that who told you that as Senator
Johnson wrote I've accurately
characterized his reaction as adamant
vehement and angry they didn't tell you
about senator Johnson's letter why not
the Democrats entire quid pro quo theory
is based on nothing more than the
initial speculation of one person
ambassador sauna that speculation is
wrong despite the Democrats hopes the
ambassador's mistaken belief does not
become true merely because he repeated
it many times and apparently too many
people Under Secretary of State David
Hale George Kent and ambassador Volker
all testified that there was no
connection whatsoever between security
assistance and investigations here is
ambassador Volker
you had a meeting with the president
States and you believe that the policy
issues that he raised concerning Ukraine
were valid correct yes the president
itíd States ever say to you that he was
not going to allow aid for the United
States to go to the Ukraine unless there
were investigations into verismo the
Biden's
or the 2016 elections no he did not did
the Ukrainians ever tell you that they
understood that they would not get a
meeting with the Pres
the United States a phone call with the
president United States military aid or
foreign aid from the United States
unless they undertook investigations of
Purisima the Biden's of the 2016
elections no they did not the house
managers never told you any of this why
not why didn't they show you this
testimony why didn't they tell you about
this testimony why didn't they put
Ambassador sunland's testimony in its
full and proper context for your
consideration because none of this fits
their narrative and it wouldn't lead to
their predetermined outcome thank you
for your attention
I yield to mr. Sekulow
mr. chief justice Majority Leader
McConnell Democratic leader Schumer
house managers members of the Senate let
me begin by saying that you cannot
simply decide this case in a vacuum mr.
Schiff said yesterday I believe it was
his father who said you should put
yourself in someone else's shoes let's
for a moment put ourselves in the shoes
of the President of the United States
right now before he was sworn into
office he was subjected to an
investigation by the Federal Bureau of
Investigation called crossfire hurricane
the president within six months of his
inauguration found a special counsel
being appointed to investigate a Russia
collusion theory in their opening
statement several members of the house
managers try to once again relitigate
the Muller case here's the bottom line
this is part one of the model report
this part alone is 199 pages the house
managers in the presentation a couple of
times referenced this for that let me
tell you something this cost thirty two
million dollars this investigation took
2,800 subpoenas this investigation had
500 search warrants this had 230 orders
for communication records this
had 500 witness interviews all to reach
the following conclusion and I'm gonna
quote from the mullah report itself it
could be found on page 173 as it relates
to this whole matter of collusion and
conspiracy ultimately is the words of
Bob Muller in his report this
investigation did not establish that the
campaign coordinated or conspired with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities let me say that
again this the mole report resulted in
this that for this ultimately the
investigation did not establish that the
campaign coordinated or conspired with
the Russian government in its election
related interference activities this for
that in his summation on Thursday night
managership complained that the
president chose not to go with the
determination of his intelligence
agencies regarding foreign interference
and instead decided that he would listen
to people that he trusted and he would
inquire about the Ukraine issue himself
mr. Schiff did not like the fact that
the president did not apparently blindly
trust some of the advice he was being
given by the intelligence agencies first
of all let me be clear
disagreeing with the president's
decision on foreign policy matters or
whose advice he's going to take is in no
way an impeachable offense second
mr. Schiff and mr. Nadler of all people
because they share significant
committees really should know this and
they should know what's happened let me
remind you of something just six tenths
of a mile from this chamber sits the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court
also known as the FISA Court it is the
federal court established and authorized
under the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act to oversee requests by
federal agencies for surveillance orders
against foreign spies inside the United
States including American citizens
because of the sensitive nature of its
business the court is a more secret
Court its hearings are closed to the
public in this court there are no
defense counsel no opportunity to
cross-examine witnesses and no ability
to test evidence the only material that
the court ever sees are those materials
that are submitted on trust on trust by
members of the intelligence community
with the presumption that they would be
acting a good faith on December 17th
2019 the FISA Court issued a scathing
order in response to the Justice
Department inspector general's report on
FBI's crossfire hurricane investigation
into whether or not the Trump campaign
was coordinating with Russia we already
know the conclusion that report detailed
the FBI's pattern and practice
systematic abuses of obtaining
surveillance order requests and the
process they utilize in its order and
this is the order from the court I'm
going to read it
this order response to reports that
personnel of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation provided false information
to the National Security Division of the
Department of Justice and withheld
material information from the NSD which
was detrimental to the FBI's case in
connection with for applications to the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court
when the FBI personnel misled NSD in the
ways that are described in these reports
they equally misled the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court this
order has been followed up
there's been another order it was
Declassified just a couple of days ago
fakes in large part the court said to
the Office of Inspector General Jewess
Department of Justice the court has
received notice of material
misstatements and omissions in
applications filed by the government in
the above captioned documents DOJ
assesses that with respect to the
applications and it lists to specific
docket numbers 17 375 and 17 679 if not
earlier there was not there was
insufficient predication to establish
probable cause to believe that carter
paige was acting as an agent of a
foreign power
the president had reason to be concerned
about the information he was being
provided
now we could we could ignore this we
could make believe this did not happen
but it did so as we begin introducing
our arguments I want to correct a couple
of things in the records as well that's
what we're doing today we in to really
intend to show over in the next several
days that the evidence is actually
really overwhelming that the president
did nothing wrong mr shipp and his
colleagues repeatedly told you that the
intelligence community assessment that
Russia was acting alone responsible for
the election interference implying that
this somehow debunked the idea that
there might be in you know interference
from other countries including Ukraine
mr. Nadler deployed a similar argument
saying that President Trump thought
quote Ukraine not Russia interfered in
our last presidential election and this
is basically what we call a straw man
argument let me be clear the house
managers in over a 23 hour period kept
pushing this false dichotomy that it was
either Russia or Ukraine but not both
they kept telling you the conclusion of
the intelligence community and mr.
Muller was Russia alone with regard to
the 2016 elections of course that's not
the report that Bob mother wrote focused
on Russian interference although there
is some information in letters regarding
Ukraine and I'm going to point to those
in a few moments in fact let me report
to talk about those letter right now
this is a letter dated May 4 2018 to mr.
Yuri
Lysenko it's the general prosecutor for
the office of the prosecutor general of
Ukraine it was a letter requesting that
his office cooperate with the mauler
investigation involving Ukraine issues
and issues involving Ukraine government
or law enforcement officials it's signed
by senator Menendez senator Leahy and
Senator Durbin I'm doing this to put
this in an entire perspective house
managers tried to tell you that the
importance
remember the whole discussion and my
colleague mr. Perot talked about this
between president Olinsky and president
Trump and the bilateral meeting in the
Oval Office at the White House as if an
article of impeachment could be based
upon a meeting not taking place in the
White House but taking place someplace
else
like the United Nations General Assembly
where it in fact did take place now dr.
Fiona Hill was quite clear in saying
that a White House meeting would supply
the new Ukrainian government with the
quote legitimacy it needed especially
visa vie the Russians and that Ukraine's
viewed the White House meeting is a
recognition of their legitimacy
legitimacy as a sovereign state but
here's what they did not play here's
what they did not tell you and I'm gonna
quote from dr. Hills testimony on page
145 of her transcript these are her
words this is what she said under oath
it wasn't always a White House meeting
per se but definitely a
presidential-level meeting you know a
meeting with szalinski and the president
I mean it could have taken place in
Poland
Warsaw it could have been you know a
proper bilateral in some other context
but in other words a White House level
presidential meeting that could be found
on page 145 and contrary to what
managership and some of the other
managers told you is this meeting that
did in fact incur it occurred at the UN
General Assembly on September 25th 2019
those were the words of dr. hill that
you did not hear this case is really not
about presidential wrongdoing this
entire impeachment process is about the
house managers insistence that they are
able to read everybody's thoughts they
can read everybody's intention even when
the principal speakers the witnesses
themselves insist that those
interpretations are wrong
managers sip managership managers Garcia
and dennings relied heavily on selected
clips from the vasa der sunland's
testimony I am NOT going to replay those
my colleague mr. purpura played those
for you
it's clear we're not gonna play the same
clips seven times he said it you saw it
that's the evidence miss Laurey and miss
Lofgren said that you know numerous
witness testified and miss a quote that
they were not provided with any reason
for why the hold was lifted on September
11th again suggesting that the
president's reason for the hold
Ukrainian corruption and burden-sharing
were somehow created after the fact but
again as my colleague just showed you
burden-sharing was raised in the
transcript itself mr. Schiff stated here
that just like the implementation of the
hold president Trump provided no reason
for the release this also is wrong in
their testimony embassadors Volcker and
Sandlin said that the president raised
his concerns about Ukrainian corruption
in the May 23rd 2019 meeting with the
Ukraine delegation deputy defense
secretary Laura craft testified that she
received an email in June of 2019
listing follow-ups from a meeting
between the secretary of defense chief
of staff and the president relating
specifically to craning security
assistance including asking about what
other countries are contributing
burden-sharing that could be found in
Laura Cooper's deposition pages 33 and
34 the president mentioned both
corruption and burn sharing to Senator
Johnson as you already heard it's also
important to note that as ambassador
David Hale testified that foreign aid
generally was undergoing a review in
2019 from page 84 of his November 6 2019
testimony he said the administration did
not want to take a sort of business as
usual approach to
assistance a feeling that once the
country has received a certain assistant
package it's something that continues
forever didn't talk about that in the 23
hour presentation dr. Fiona Hill
confirmed this review and testified on
November 24 2019 I'm and again quote
from page 75 of her testimony that quote
there had been a directive for wholesale
a whole scale review of our foreign
policy foreign policy assistance and the
ties between our foreign policy
objectives and that assistance this had
been going on actually for many months
so multiple witnesses testified that the
president had long-standing concerns and
specific concerns about Ukraine the
house managers understandably
understandably ignore the testimony that
took place before their own committees
in her testimony of October 14th 2019
dr. hill testified at pages 118 and 119
of her transcript that she thinks the
president has actually quite publicly
said that he was very skeptical about
corruption in Ukraine and then she said
again in her testimony and in fact he's
not alone because everyone because
everyone has expressed great concerns
about corruption in Ukraine similarly
ambassador Jovanovic testified that they
all had concerns about corruption in
Ukraine and as noted on pages 142 of her
deposition transcript when asked what
she knew about the president's
deep-rooted skepticism about Ukraine's
business environment she answered that
President Trump delivered an
anti-corruption men's message to former
ukrainian President poroshenko in their
first meeting
in the White House on June 20th 2017 NSC
senior director Marcin confirmed on
November 19th 2019 at page 63 in his
testimony transcript that this was
during the volcker Marcin public hearing
that he was aware that the president
thought Ukraine had a corruption problem
his words again and he continued as did
many others familiar with Ukraine and
according to her October 30th 2019
testimony a special advisor for Ukraine
negotiations at the State Department
Catherine Croft also heard the president
raised the issue of corruption directly
with then President poroshenko of
Ukraine during a bilateral meeting at
the United Nations General Assembly this
time in September of 2017
special advisor cropped testified she
also understood the president's
concerned that quote Ukraine is corrupt
because she has been Miz's her words
tasked to write a paper to help then NSA
head McMasters general investors make
the case of the president in connection
with prior prior security assistance
these concerns were entirely justified
when asked and I'm again a quote from
dr. Hills October 14 29 hearing
transcript transcript certainly these
are her words eliminating corruption
Ukraine was one of if the central goals
of a foreign policy now does anybody
think that one election of one president
that ran on a reform platform who
finally gets a majority
in their legislative body that
corruption in Ukraine just evaporates
that's like looking at this and goes
back to the model report you can't look
at these issues in a vacuum
virtually every witness agreed that
confronting corrupt should be at the
forefront of US policy now I think
there's some other things we have to
understand about timing this again is
according to the testimony of Tim Marcin
his testimony and this isn't when
President Solinsky was first elected
there was this is there was real these
are his words concern about whether he
would be a genuine reformer and whether
he would generally try to root out
corruption it was also at this time this
was before the election unclear whether
president solinsky's party would
actually be able to get a workable
majority I think we're all glad that
they did to say that that's been tested
or determined that corruption Ukraine
has been removed the anti-corruption
Court of Ukraine did not commence its
work until September 5th of 2019 121
days ago four months ago we're acting as
if there was a magic wand that there was
new elections and everything was now
fine
I will not because we're gonna hear more
about it get into some of the meetings
the Vice President had you'll hear that
in the days ahead
manager Krause said this what's most
interesting to me about this is that
President Crump was only interested in
Ukraine aid his words nobody else the US
provides aids to dozens of countries
around the world lots of partners and
allies he'd asked he didn't ask about
any of them just Ukraine I appreciate
your service for our country I really do
I didn't serve in the military and I
appreciate that but let's get our facts
straight
that is what manager Krause said here's
what actually happened President Trump
has placed holds on aid a number of
times we just take basic due diligence
to figure this out in September 2019 the
administration announced that it was
withholding over 100 million dollars in
aid to Afghanistan over concerns about
government corruption in August 20 19 %
Trump announced that the administration
and salt were in talks to substantially
increase South Korea's share
burden-sharing of the expenses of US
military aid support for South Korea in
June President Trump
cut or paused over 550 million dollars
in foreign aid to El Salvador Honduras
and Guatemala because those countries
were not fairly sharing the burdens of
preventing mass migration to the United
States in June the administration
temporarily paused 105 million dollars
in aid to Lebanon the administration
lifted that hold in December with one
official explaining that the
administration continually reviews and
thoroughly evaluates the effectiveness
of all United States foreign assistance
to ensure that funds go towards
activities that further US foreign
policy and also further our national
security interest like any
administration would in September 2018
the administration canceled the 300
million dollar three hundred million
dollars in military aid to Pakistan
because it was not meaning its
counterterrorism obligations you didn't
hear about any of that from my
Democratic colleagues the house managers
none of that was discussed under
secretary Hale again his transcript said
that quote aid has been withheld from
several countries of cloth across the
globe for various reasons dr. hill
similarly explained that there was a
freeze put on all kinds of aid also
freezes put on assistance because it was
in the process at the time of an awful
lot of reviews going on on foreign
assistance that's the hill deposition
transcript she added this was one of the
star witnesses for the managers she
added this again not played that in her
experience stops and starts or sometimes
common with foreign assistance and that
the Office of Management and Budget
holds up dollars all the time including
in the past for dollars going to Ukraine
in the past
similarly ambassador Volcker affirmed
that aid gets held up from time to time
for a whole assortment of reasons
manager crow told you that the
president's Ukraine policy was not
strong against Russian noting that we
helped our partner fight Russia over
there so we don't have to fight Russia
here our friends on the front lines and
trenches and with sneakers and this was
following the Russians invasion of
Ukraine in 2014 the United States has
stood by Ukraine those are your words
while it's true that the United States
has stood by Ukraine since the invasion
of 2014 only one president says then
took a very concrete step some of you
supported it
and that step included actually
providing Ukraine with legal lethal
weapons including javelin missiles
that's the President Trump did summon
you in this very room
some of you managers actually support of
that here's what ambassador Taylor said
that you didn't hear in the 23 hours you
didn't hear this javelin missiles are
serious weapons they will kill Russian
tanks ambassador Jovanovic agreed
stating that Ukraine policy under
presidents from president Trump actually
got stronger stronger than it was under
President Obama there's talks about
sanctions president Trump has also
imposed heavy sanctions on Russia for
president szalinski thanked him the
United States has imposed heavy
sanctions on Russia president Zielinski
thanked him manager Jeffrey said that
the idea that Trump cares about
corruption is laughable this is what dr.
hill said they didn't play this
eliminating corruption in Ukraine was
one of if not the central goal of u.s.
foreign policy in Ukraine let me say
that again dr. hill testified that
eliminating corruption in Ukraine was
one of if not the central goal of u.s.
foreign policy in Ukraine you're taking
notes you can find that at the hill
deposition transcript 34 : 7 through 13
dr. hill also said that she thinks the
president is actually quite publicly
said that he was very skeptical about
corruption in Ukraine in fact he's not
alone she said this as well everyone has
expressed again great concerns about
corruption ambassador Jovanovic they
didn't play this she also said we all
had concerns
national security director Marcin
confirmed that quote he was aware that
the president thought Ukraine had a
corruption problem as did many other
people familiar with it
I am NOT gonna continue to go over and
over and over again good the evidence
that they did not put before you because
we would be here for a lot longer than
24 hours but to say that the President
of the United States did not was not
concerned about burden Sharon sharing
that he was not concerned about
corruption Ukraine the facts from their
hearing the facts from their hearing
establish exactly the opposite the
president wasn't concerned about burn
sharing read all of the records and then
there was mr. Shipp saying yesterday
maybe we can learn a lot more from our
Ukrainian ally let me read you what our
Ukrainian Ally said president Solinsky
when asked about these allegations of
quid pro quo he said I think you read
everything I think you read the text he
says we had a good phone call these are
his words it was normal we spoke about
many things I think and you read it that
nobody pushed me they think you can read
minds I think you look at the words
mathilde balance of my time to my
colleague the deputy White House Council
had film and he's going to address two
issues so we're gonna try to do this in
a very systematic way over the days
ahead
oh okay one involving issues related to
because this came up near the end of
their so I want to do this in a sequence
obstruction as relates to some of the
subpoenas that were issued he's also
gonna touch on some of the due process
issues since it was at the end of
there's and fresh in everybody's mind
mr. chief justice
riveting defense and spirit of Donald
Trump of course mr. chief justice
senators Majority Leader McConnell
Democratic leader Schumer
good morning as mr. Sekulow said I'm
going to touch on a couple of issues
related to obstruction and due process
just to hit on some points before we go
into more detail in the rest of our
presentation I'd like to start with one
of the points that manager Jeffries
focused a lot on towards the end of the
presentation yesterday related to the
obstruction charge in the second article
of impeachment because he tried to
portray a picture of what he called
blanket defiance that there was a
response from the Trump administration
that was simply we won't cooperate with
anything we won't give you any documents
we won't do anything and it was blanket
defiance really without explanation that
that was all there was was just an
assertion that we wouldn't cooperate and
he said and I pulled this from the
transcript that president Trump's
objections are not generally rooted in
the law and are not legal arguments
that's simply not true it is true that's
simply not true in every instance when
there was resistance to a subpoena
resistance to a subpoena for a witness
or for documents there was a legal
explanation of the justification for it
yes when you came up with that they
focused a lot on an October 8th letter
from the counsel to the president
Padstow baloney but they didn't show you
an October 18th letter which is up on
the screen now that went through in
detail why subpoenas that had been
issued by manager shifts committees were
invalid because the house has not
authorized your committees to conduct
any such inquiry or to subpoena
information in furtherance of it
and that was because the house had not
taken a vote to authorize the committee
to exercise the power of impeachment to
issue any compulsory process and I'm
going to get into that issue in just a
moment not only were there was there a
legal explanation a specific reason for
every resistance not just blanket
defiance every step that the
administration is a short one I'm glad
to just jump in and answer super chats
and questions as they come in that I'm
glad to do that if people want me to
claimed in our brief and you the major
opinion from the office of legal counsel
is actually attached in our trial
memorandum as an appendix
now mr. Jeffries and other managers also
suggested that the Trump administration
took the approach of no negotiation
blanket refusal and no attempt to
accommodate that's also not true in the
October 8th letter that mr. Sibal Oni
assent to speaker Pelosi and said
explicitly quote if the committee's wish
to return to the regular order of
oversight requests we stand ready to
engage in that process as we have in the
past in a manner consistent with
well-established bipartisan
constitutional protections and a respect
for the separation of powers enshrined
in the Constitution end quote
it was manager Schiff and his committees
that did not want to engage in any
accommodation process we had said that
we were willing to explore that command
house managers have also asserted a
number of times this came up on that
first long night when we were here until
2:00 as well that the Trump
administration never asserted executive
privilege never asserted executive
privilege and I explained at the time
that's technically true but misleading
misleading because the rationale on
which the subpoenas were resisted never
depended on an assertion of executive
privilege each of the rationales that we
have it sounds like there's someone in
the chamber playing some kind of a video
game on their phone I don't know how
many people are hearing that a few
things coming in via super chat that I
want to mention Andrew diffenbach
mentioned we underestimate Trump's
genius the wheel was probably invented
in mus Mesopotamia modern-day Iraq we
need to protect the body of the wheel
inventor yeah trump's weird comments
about we need to protect American
inventors like the one that invented the
wheel a quick notes M Donahue says
thanks David for your hard work and
emotional intelligence
Shane Vaness says looks like their go-to
is going to be burden-sharing to
legitimize the call from the full
transcript they release these people
make me want to vomit lava yeah they're
just they're just lying I mean and and I
saw a question at the very bottom here
Christy J says will lies by the lawyers
be prosecuted of course not no they
won't be no thanks says how can we trust
the integrity of our vote in November we
can't we just need to overwhelm the vote
by so much that the lack of integrity
won't change the results J Harper says
such a low energy defense
sad and Marika L says Fox is showing
this without muting or interfering as is
typical could it help anyway as the
defense is so flimsy
yeah Fox during a lot of the house
manager presentation for the last three
days was running my pillow commercials
and commentary over the presentations
now all of a sudden Fox wants to present
the the unvarnished presentations of
Donald Trump's sycophantic defenders let
me quickly thank over on twitch and then
we'll listen back to a little bit of
this scatter Lackey
subscribed with prime philbo swaggins
subscribed it's here one meow the great
subscribed with prime and fawn nation
says CBS reported that Trump's staff
threatened Republicans to vote against
impeachment or find their heads on a
spike
Adam Schiff mentioned it in his closing
arguments last night thanks for letting
me know I I did miss that I will do new
member thank-yous as they come in coupon
code and
each 50 saves you 50% at join pakman.com
the number one way to support the stream
let's get back to Patrick Philbin and
then in a few moments I'll pop back in
and answer some more super chat
questions that he would have a committee
receive evidence handle that submit a
recommendation to the Senate and that
would be the way that the trial would
occur without a vote from the Senate to
give authority to that committee I don't
think so it doesn't make sense that's
not the way the Constitution assigns
that Authority riveting and it's the
same in the house here there was no vote
to authorize a committee to exercise the
power of impeachment and this law has
been boiled down by the DC Circuit in
Exxon corpuses FTC to explain it this
way to issue a valid subpoena a
committee or subcommittee must conform
strictly to the resolution establishing
its investigatory powers there must be a
resolution voted on by the parent body
to give the committee that power and the
problem here is there is no standing
rule there was no standing Authority
giving manager shifts committee the
authority to use the power of
impeachment to issue compulsory process
rule 10 of the house discusses
legislative authority it doesn't mention
a peep impeachment and that is why in
every presidential impeachment in
history the house has initiated the
inquiry off via voting to give a
committee the authority to pursue that
inquiry so contrary to what manager
Jeffrey's suggested there has always
been in every presidential impeachment
inquiry a vote from the full house to
authorize a committee and that is the
only way the inquiry begins there were
three different votes for the
impeachment of President Andrew Johnson
in January 1867 in March 1867 and in
February 1868 for President Nixon
chairman Rodino of the House Judiciary
Committee explained there was a move to
have him issue subpoenas after the
Saturday night massacre and they
determined that they did not have that
authority in the House Judiciary
Committee without a vote from the house
and he determined as he explained that a
resolution has always been passed by the
house it is a necessary step if we are
to meet our obligations there's been
reference to investigate Ori activities
starting in the House Judiciary
Committee in the Nixon impeachment prior
to the vote from the house but all that
the committee was doing was assembling
publicly available information and
information that had been gathered by
other congressional committees if people
are wondering where and all this is a
defense of Trump's actions it's missing
it must be hidden under a rug somewhere
in the back of the Senate chamber
Gaylord Winchester 77 says by super chat
no witty comment just appreciate the
show thank you matt bond says via super
chat I'm waiting for the Chewbacca
defense from South Park actually I don't
think I've seen a South Park episode in
15 years it's not my thing
as the kids these days say so I don't I
don't know what that is yeah not this is
not really a spirited defense of what
Donald Trump did this is a very
low-energy defense of arcane and and
sort of obscure procedural issues
the House Judiciary Committee explained
I'm quoting because the issue of
impeachment is of such overwhelming
importance the committee decided that it
must receive authorization from the full
house before proceeding on any further
course of action because impeachment is
delegated solely to the House of
Representatives by the Constitution the
Full House of Representatives should be
involved in critical decision-making
regarding various stages of impeachment
here the House Democrats skipped over
that step completely what they had
instead was simply a press conference
from Speaker Pelosi announcing that she
was directing committees to proceed with
an impeachment inquiry against the
President of the United States
speaker Pelosi didn't have the authority
to delegate the power of the house to
those committees on her own so why does
it matter right that's the question
we're won it matters because the
Constitution places that authority in
the house and ensures that there is a
democratic check on the exercise of that
authority that there will have to be a
vote by the full house before there can
be a proceeding to start inquiring into
impeaching the President of the United
States so let me in what's going on here
what what they are arguing and again we
knew that this is what they were going
to do they are saying Nancy Pelosi
announced an impeachment inquiry and
then they did the inquiry in the
judiciary in the Intel committee and in
the Judiciary Committee as you're
supposed to do and then they voted in
those committees to move forward with
impeachment and then took to a full vote
and then they did the full vote in the
house and they voted to impeach and they
impeach the president and then sent the
articles to the Senate and what their
defense is is that between Nancy Pelosi
announcing an inquiry and the inquiry
starting they needed a full vote in the
House on the inquiry okay that's their
argument now of course that vote would
have passed whether or not it's
necessary is what is being debated but
if you're wondering how does this in any
way relate to the thing
Donald Trump has been impeached for I'll
give you it the answer here's the answer
key at the back of the book it doesn't
it doesn't relate to that let me say
thanks and welcome to Jeffrey Schneider
Jeffrey Schneider is new member number
161 really appreciate that the goal
today is 175 let's get let's get back to
Patrick Philbin there's that they
offered the president due process at the
House Judiciary Committee and manager so
I just I retweet described it sorry let
me lay is that he I reached I tweeted an
updated Trump lawyer bingo card due
process is oh no I ended up removing due
process I didn't have to had due process
on here and I didn't have it we've heard
a lot of these so far by the way if
people are playing along with my bingo
card not sure how many people are lean
what actually happened and I should I
should note before I get into those
details there was a suggestion also the
due process is not required in the house
proceeding that it's simply a privilege
but that wasn't the position that
manager Nadler has taken in the past in
2016 he said quote the power of
impeachment is a solemn responsibility
assigned to the House by the
Constitution and to this committee by
our peers that responsibility demands a
rigorous level of due process and in the
Clinton impeachment in 1998 he explained
what does due process mean it means
among other things the right to confront
the witnesses against you to call your
own witnesses and to have the assistance
of counsel now I think we all know that
all of those rights were denied to the
president in the first two rounds of
hearings the first round of secret
hearings in the basement bunker where
managership had three committees holding
hearings that's definitely here secret
basement hearing it's hearing testimony
they don't know they're in the bunker
and have it
in a public televised setting which was
totally unprecedented in any
presidential impeachment inquiry in both
the Clinton and the Nixon inquiries for
every public hearing the president was
allowed to be present by counsel and
cross-examine witnesses but the house
managers say that's all right because
when we got to the third round of
hearings after people had testified
twice then we were going to allow the
president to have some due process but
the way that played out was this first
they scheduled a hearing for December
4th that was going to hear solely from
law professors and by the time they
wanted the president to commit whether
he would participate it was unclear they
couldn't specify how many law professors
or who the law professors were going to
be and the president's counsel wrote
back and declined to participate in that
but at the same time manager Nadler had
asked what other rights under the House
Resolution 661 the House inquiry the
president would like to exercise and the
president's counsel wrote back asking
specific questions in order it's just
shocking that they consider this even
remotely useful Jason Ealing says via
super chat this guy is so passionate
yeah he just has passion bleeding out of
his ears thorald for beck says I'm
getting physically ill from watching
this we are in a post fact era and
without objective truth there is no such
thing as democratic debate very well
said it's me John B says any impressions
or opinions on the news of Bernie's rise
in Iowa polls as of this morning no I
haven't been following that and I tend
not to over the weekend I will review
all of the polling information in time
for the for the Monday shows yet not
that this is um that we're continuing
here with what we expected sort of
procedural type arguments about how
unfair the whole process has been with
the law professors the first hearing
before the Judiciary Committee and on
December 5th the morning of December 5th
Speaker Pelosi announced the conclusion
of the entire Judiciary Committee
process because she announced that she
was directing chairman Nadler to draft
articles of impeachment so the
conclusion of the whole process was
already set then after the close of
business on the fifth we learned from
the staff that the committee had no
plans other than a hearing on December
9th to hear from staffers who had
prepared hypsi committee reports they
had no plans to have other hearings no
plans to hear from fact witnesses no
plans to do any factual investigation so
the president was given a choice of
participating in a process that was
going to already have the outcome
determined Kelly there's gonna already
said articles of impeachment going to be
drafted and where there were no plans to
hear from any fact witnesses that's not
due process shouldn't use process as I
think okay fine to participate in that
process because the Judiciary Committee
had already decided they're going to
accept an ex parte record developed in
manager shifts process and there was no
point in participating in that so the
idea that there was due process offered
to the president is simply not accurate
the entire proceedings in the house from
the time of the September 4th press
conference until the Judiciary Committee
began marking up articles of impeachment
on December 11th WestEd 78 days it's the
fastest investigatory process for a
presidential impeachment in history and
for 71 days of that process for 71 days
of the hearings and the taking of depth
and hearing testimony the president was
completely locked out
he couldn't be represented by counsel he
couldn't cross-examine a women visioning
being caught in the corner at a dinner
party where this guy is making these
arguments to you when you're trying to
figure out did I just miss the mini
quiches that said did I just miss that
missed the opportunity for a mini quiche
because this guy just will not stop
talking to me he raised earlier why
would you have a process like that what
does that tell you about the process as
we've pointed out a couple of times
cross-examination in our legal system is
regarded as the greatest legal engine
ever invented for the discovery of truth
it's essential the Supreme Court has
said in Goldberg versus Kelly for any
determination that's important that
requires determining facts
cross-examination has been one of the
keys for due process why did they design
a mechanism here where the president was
locked out and denied the ability to
cross-examine witnesses it's because
they weren't really interested in
getting at the facts and the truth the
head of timetable to meet they wanted to
have impeachment done by Christmas and
that's what they were striving to do no
I'm convinced as slate shift in Gears I
want to touch on one last point before I
yield to one of my colleagues yeah and
that relates to the whistleblower uh-oh
the whistleblower who we haven't heard
that much about who started all of this
right the whistleblower we know
from a letter that the Inspector General
of the intelligence community slowly
shifting into first adhere thought early
that the whistleblower had political
bias we don't know exactly what the
political bias was because the Inspector
General testified in the House
committees in an executive session and
that transcript is still secret
it wasn't transmitted up to the House
Judiciary Committee we haven't seen it
we don't know what's in it
we don't know what he was asked and what
he revealed about the whistleblower now
you would think that before in going
forward with an impeachment proceeding
against the President of the United
States that you would want to find out
something about the complainant that had
started all because motivations bias
reasons for wanting to bring this
complaint it could be relevant but there
wasn't any inquiry into that recent
reports public reports suggest that
potentially the whistleblower was
intelligent community intelligence
community staffer who worked with then
Vice President Biden on Ukraine matters
which if true would suggest an even
greater reason for wanting to know about
potential bias or motive for the
whistleblower and at first when things
started it seemed like everyone agreed
that we should hear from the
whistleblower including manager shift I
think we have what he said but yes we
would love to talk directly with the
whistleblower we'll get the unfiltered
testimony of that whistleblower we don't
need the whistleblower who have a
stating video right at first manager
Schiff agreed we should hear the
unfiltered testimony from the
whistleblower but then he changed his
mind
and he suggested that it was because now
we had the transcript but the second
clip there was from October 29th which
was four days after the transcript had
been released but there was something
else that came into play and that was
something to manage a shift had said
earlier when he was asked about whether
he had spoken to the whistleblower we
have not spoken directly with the
whistleblower we would like to and it
turned out that that statement was not
truthful around October 2nd or 3rd it
was exposed that the manager shifts
staff at least had spoken with the
whistleblower Trump can't be watching
this and enjoying it right let me read a
couple of other super super chats that
came in eric Virk ver Creason says so
why are they blocking witnesses then
yeah this is a constant thing we they
haven't heard from the types of
witnesses they would consider
substantive and they are blocking the
types of witnesses that they would
consider substantive also thanks to
Danielle Goldman for the super chat I
appreciate that
let's let's continue and that creates a
real problem from a due process
perspective from a search for truth
perspective because he was an interested
fact witness at that point he had a
reason since he had been caught out
saying something that wasn't truthful
about that contact he had a reason to
not want that inquiry and it was he who
ensured that there wasn't any inquiry
into that now
this is relevant here I think because as
you've heard from my colleagues a lot of
what we've heard over the past 23 hours
over the past three days has been from
chairmanship and he has been telling you
things like what's in president Trump's
head what's in president zelinsky's head
it's all his interpretation of the facts
and the evidence trying to pull
inferences out of things and there's
another statement the chairmanship made
that I think we have on video circum all
you have right now is a circumstantial
case actually no Chuck I can tell you
that the case is more than that and I
can't go into the particulars but there
is more than circumstantial evidence now
so again I think do you have seen direct
evidence of collusion I don't want to go
into specifics but I will say that there
is evidence that is not circumstantial
and and is very much worthy of
investigation so that was in March of
2017 when chairmanship is ranking member
of hips II was telling the public the
American public that he had more than
circumstantial evidence through his
position on hypsi that president Trump's
campaign had colluded with Russia now of
course the motor I'm sure some 90 year
old senator in the back of the room is
like they're talking about hepatitis C
now what is this all about a rowdy
peacock says via super chat fascinating
that they can argue that the president
was simultaneously locked out from and
declining to participate in the process
both are somehow unfair to the president
well said that's just one one way in
which none of this makes sense
Ricky Williams says unrelated Democrats
should invite the Central Park five and
others to sit directly in front of Trump
during his State of the Union speech
well the guests sit up top that they
wouldn't be able to sit right in front
of Trump we will be doing the State of
the Union
live next Tuesday February 4th uh
there's discussion of it maybe being
changed the schedule being changed
because of the impeachment trial but
we'll see Thoreau fir Beck says outing a
whistleblower is a crime what's wrong
with people there are laws in place to
protect them from exactly this how can
this be happening they don't care Beck
that's what you need to understand they
don't care about that they care about
scoring political points if they can and
we would submit that they have not been
and that that is relevant for your
consideration with that I will you to my
colleague mr. Cephalonia Cipollone e
coming back now nightmare right mr.
Chief Justice members of the Senate I
have good news just a few more minutes
from us today but I want to point out a
couple of points point out point number
one just to follow up on what mr.
Philbin just told you do you know who
else didn't show up in the Judiciary
Committee to answer questions about his
report in the way done safeguarded in
the Clinton impeachment Ken Starr was
subjected to cross-examination by the
president's counsel do you know who
didn't show up in the Judiciary
Committee chairmanship
he did not show up he did not give
chairman Nadler the respect of appearing
before his committee and answering
questions from this committee he did
send his staff but why didn't he show up
another law says you should think about
now they've come here today and they
basically said
let's cancel an election over a meeting
with the Ukraine with Ukraine overturn
election as my colleagues have shown
they fail to give you key facts about
the meeting and lots of other evidence
but they produce themselves but let's
talk about the meeting they said it was
all about an invitation to a meeting if
you look at the first transcript where
is the very first round the president
said to president Solinsky when you're
settled in and ready I'd like to invite
you to the White House well had a lot of
things to talk about but we're with you
all the way and president szalinski said
well thank you for the invitation we
accept the invitation and look forward
to the visit thank you again
then president Solinsky got a letter on
May 29th inviting him again to come to
the White House so understand that the
important thing about all of this is
that the case they are pointing out with
single line excerpts from communications
is it pretends that none of these other
things were going on ranging from
physical surveillance of Murray
Ivanovich to conversations being had by
other people and you this is not how
diplomacy actually works this you don't
strongarm someone in letters that are
gonna be made public I look forward to
seeing you President Solinsky replied
thank you very much I would be very
happy to come and would be happy to meet
with you personally and get to know you
better
I'm looking forward to our meeting and I
also would like to invite you to visit
Ukraine and come to the city of Keith
which is a beautiful city we have a
beautiful country which would welcome
you
then he said on the other hand I believe
on September 1 we will be in Poland and
we can meet in Poland hopefully now they
didn't read you that part of the
transcript and they didn't tell you what
happened a meeting in Poland was
scheduled president Trump was scheduled
to go to Poland he was scheduled to meet
with president Solinsky
what happened President Trump couldn't
go to Poland why because there was a
hurricane in the United States and he
thought it would be better for him to
stay here to help deal with the
hurricane really taking president wind
why didn't they tell you that why didn't
they tell you that presidents Galinski
suggest that hey how about we meet in
Poland
why didn't you tell them that that
meeting was scheduled and had to be
canceled for a hurricane this entire
thing is really a weather related
impeachment if you think about it so
that was our first question that we
asked you you heard a lot of facts that
they didn't tell you facts that are
critical facts that they know completely
collapsed their case on the facts now
you heard a lot from them you're not
gonna hear facts from the president's
lawyers they're not gonna talk to you
about the facts that's all we've done
today and ask yourself ask yourself
given the facts you've heard today that
they didn't tell you who doesn't want to
talk about the facts who doesn't want to
talk about the facts the American people
paid a lot of money for those facts they
paid a lot of money for this
investigation and they didn't bother to
tell you ask yourself why if they don't
want to be fair to the president at
least out of respect for all of you they
should be fair to you they should tell
you these things and when they don't
tell you these things it means something
so think about that
impeachment shouldn't be a shell game
they should give you the facts
that's all we have for today we asked
you out of respect to think about think
about whether what you've heard would
really suggest to anybody anything other
that would be completely irresponsible
abuse of power to do what they're asking
you to do to stop an election to
interfere in an election and the remove
the president of the United States from
the ballot let the people decide for
themselves that's what the founders
wanted that's what we should all want
and with that I thank you for your
attention and I look forward to seeing
you on Monday Wow the majority the
majority leader is recognized mr. Chief
Justice I ask unanimous consent the
trial adjourn until 1:00 p.m. Monday
January 27th and that this order also
constitute the adjournment of the Senate
without objection so ordered the Senate
is adjourned
a short-day today and as predicted
Donald Trump's attorneys laying out a
mostly a procedural and what about is
what about ISM defense of Donald Trump
Jay Sekulow and Pat's a baloney and the
guy whose name of Pat Hutchins Hutchins
Phillip Phillip Phillip Hutchins who put
everybody to sleep with the stuff of
dinner party nightmares as I would I
would refer to it I will hang out for as
long as people have questions and
comments via via super chat as as you
may I hope people played along with
Trump lawyer bingo during today's
hearing Donald Trump of course tweeting
completely out of control throughout
this entire entire thing Joanna
oh and by the way any last members that
want to push us closer to 175 I think we
might be able to do it here the website
is join pakman.com the coupon code is
impeach 50 that's the best way to
support these streams and I really
appreciate everybody who's been doing so
get your name said now by signing up at
join pakman.com Johanna Roy says you
don't need to hear from the
whistleblower after you've heard from
nine witnesses confirming what the
boys'll blower said I've been pointing
this out for a very long time I've been
pointing this out for a while
lucio Rob thanks for the super chat
appreciate it Alex R says is Sippel Oney
asking the Democrats to add more days at
this point it anyone's guess is as good
as mine as to what it is that they want
the euphy o answer says but Trump played
golf during hurricane Dorian yeah that
was it actually unexpected turn starting
to blame this as a misunderstanding
caused by a hurricane that I did not
expect and I didn't know that did not
know that was going to happen
Zachary Monroe says who else is falling
asleep watching the Republican defense
it is going to be more amusing with Rudy
Giuliani since he's a loose cannon I
don't know that there are people who are
advising Trump that I don't believe are
going to be testifying that includes
Rudy Giuliani Alan Dershowitz Ken Starr
I there on the legal team Pam Bondi but
I don't believe they are going to be
testifying Christie J says the
Republican Party really going to allow
the downfall of government not sure I
know what you mean Christie but they are
certainly participating in making a
mockery of how checks and balances are
supposed to work Dennis clump says you
can tell their defense is weak by how
slow they talk stretching every wretched
word to make it the 24 hours they
actually said Dennis they don't expect
to go the full 24 hours
Ronnie scar says no one believes the
White House Counsel not even themselves
but some wish so hard they just make it
true the nature of a cults ron Hubbard
says thoughts on the Joe Rogan Bernie
endorsement Monday I'm gonna have a big
commentary about that Monday so I don't
want to preempt it now and thanks to
thanks to Brooke Winsett for signing up
for a YouTube subscription at the soy
boy level if you're watching on twitch
twitch what which is not chopped liver I
want to invite anybody watching on
twitch to re-up their twitch prime
subscriptions or create a new one or do
a tier one subscription all
very much welcome I want to say welcome
and thank you - Phoebe Sheldon Phoebe
Sheldon is new member number 160 -
thanks Phoebe I do appreciate your
support and that of everybody else who
has signed up at join pakman.com let's
see the latest from Donald Trump's
Twitter account Donald Trump retweeting
the live c-span feed and talking about
his case against lyin cheatin little
Adam shifty shift cryin Chuck Schumer
nervous Nancy Pelosi their leader dumb
as a rock
AOL see that's actually kind of funny
particularly because AOC has nothing to
do with these proceedings whatsoever and
it's not clear what what what relevance
she has to the entire thing let's see if
PBS is live with any impeachment stuff
they have been doing all sorts of
different streams they do seem to be
they're still they're still going at it
so to speak
amazing amazing what we have seen today
let me say welcome to Eric Simon Eric C
Mon is new member number 163 Eric thank
you so much very much appreciate your
support as I said before when we get to
175 I will give out a free item from the
David Pakman show online store to
whoever is new member number 175 and
also thanks to fat hole
fat hole over on Twitch you can tell
who's on twitch and who's on YouTube
because if I say thanks to Ronnie scar
then you know that's YouTube if I say
thanks to fat hole you know that that's
coming on twitch fat hole is a twitch
subscriber 661 661 thanks to our
moderators for continuing to use the
banhammer which is of course free to get
a lot of the trolls out of our out of
the stream we are dealing with a lot of
trolls over on on YouTube in particular
basically BOTS yeah Mary Konrad Mary
Konrad is new member number 164 thanks
Mary welcome I appreciate
your support Mary taking advantage known
Mary not taking advantage of the coupon
code impeach 50 choosing to choosing to
pay full price as it were and very much
worth it I must say indeed okay thank
you so much
so upcoming schedule the the president's
defense council is allocated 24 hours
for their defense not a spirited defense
so far in fact quite the opposite they
only used about two hours today meaning
they still have 22 hours remaining they
can use those on Monday and Tuesday but
they said they don't expect to use the
full 24 hours their line was we don't
expect to need the full 24 hours to
exonerate donald trump ron Hubbard asks
when will you go back on Joe Rogan or
more podcasts well right now with
everything going on I'm I'm pretty busy
in terms of going on other podcasts of
course the Joe Rogan experience is one
of the biggest podcasts in the world and
I would interrupt whatever I was doing
to go and reappear with Joe because it
would be it was hugely beneficial to my
platform to beyond with Joe Rogan and
yeah I would I would love to do it I
would do it absolutely any time
absolutely any time that Joe wants to
have me back so Monday we will resume at
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time and anticipate
them going potentially till 9:00 or
10:00 p.m. and and or maybe not a given
that they said they're not planning to
use the full time Tuesday we will
similarly presumably hear from Trump's
defense counsel and then I believe
Wednesday the debate will start over
witnesses documents and audio-visual
records Val McLin Chi checking in via
super chat says my profile pic says hi
all right well thank you Val I
appreciate that since it is a short day
I will take advantage of it and get
going myself thanks to everybody who
joined me on this Saturday we will see
you back here Monday Monday no stream
tomorrow nothing happening tomorrow